من جانبه اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان الولايات المتحده تبحث مع حلفائها
خيارات اخرى لمبادره الحبوب مستبعدا
امكانيه تعويض كميات الحبوب بهذه المبادره
وعبر خلال منتدى معهد اسبن في كولورادو عن
امره ان يراقب العالم كيف تتلاعب روسيا
بالغذاء من اجل تحقيق اهدافها في اوكرانيا
حسب تعبيره وقال انه لا يرى اي دليل على
اهتمام روسيا باجراء محادثات السلام هادفه
في اوكرانيا واكدها ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد لا يزال في بدايته وان لدى
اوكرانيا ما تحتاجه لتحقيق اهداف هذا
الهجوم مشيرا الى ان المعدات والقوات
المدربه ستصنع الفرق في الاشهر المقبله
وبشان العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه قال انه
تحدث مع نظرائه في بجين بش ان قلقي واشنطن
من استهدافها مضيفا انا بلاده ستتخذ
الاجراء المناسب اذا دعت الضروره على حد
تعبيره
يظن الينا منه كولورادو مراسل الجزيره
محمد العلمي محمد
هذه الكلمات التي
القيت وتلقى هل سيتم صياغتها في بيان
مشترك
ليس بالضروره جمال هذا المنتدى الغايه من
تشكيله في هذا المحيط او الجو الطبيعي
البعيد عن واشنطن في مكان اقرب الى منتجع
منه الى مقر لصنع القرارات والسياسات
الغرض منه هو الابتعاد عن برقيه واشنطن
والحديث بحريه بين المسؤولين الحريين
والسابقين المدنيين وعسكريين من امريكا
وخارج امريكا واكاديميين وصحفيين ايضا من
اجل بحث
على القلب بالنسبه لهذه الدوره بحث طبيعه
التحديات التي تواجهها امريكا تحديدا
والمجتمع الدولي ايضا فيما يتعلق بقضايا
السياسه الخارجيه والامن القومي بالنسبه
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي انتهى قبل
قليل فقط من حديثه
لرواد المنت
الحديث طال جميع القضايا تقريبا التي تهم
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه الداخليه لان
المقابله بدات
بالظروف المحيطه بعبور الجندي الامريكي
الحدود الكوريه بين الكوريهتين الجنوبيه
الشماليه الى حدود المنتخب النسوي
الامريكي لكره القدم في نهائيات كاس
العالم بالنسبه للصين يبدو ان هذه العلاقه
مازالت تراوح مكانها هناك عدم تواصل
يهدد هذه العلاقه ربما اكثر الولايات
المتحده تحاول التواصل
من اجل معرفه مصير هذا الجندي الامريكي
لكن يبدو ان الكوريين الشماليين لا يردون
على مكالمات الامريكيين والوسيط الوحيد
الذي يستطيع ان يفعل ذلك هو الصين ولا
يبدو ان الصين مهتمه الان لمساعده
الامريكيين في ذلك كما في ق المناخ حيث ان
جونكيري المبعوث الامريكي للمناخ لم يستطع
اقناع الصينيين في الاتفاق على حد ادنى
لتخفيض نسبه الاحتباس الحراري على رغم من
كون الصين الملوث الاول في العالم وامريكا
هي الملوثه الثانيه وهنا قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي ان هذه هي المكان
الوحيده التي تفضل امريكا ان تكون فيها في
المرتبه الثانيه وراء شكرا
تتعلق بالصين موضوع استهداف الحسابات
الالكترونيه لوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
شكرا لك محمد العالمي الجزيره متحدثا
الينا من كولورادو